un mois avant noël est déjà allé sapa et
se vendent rapidement comme un boom en
temps de pandémie
c'est vraiment mettre dans l'ambiance
puis comme j'ai vu c'est sa première
année qui va vraiment profiter de noël
fait que c'est pour ça qu'on en profite
l'on prend cependant parmi les acheteurs
des milliers de québécois comme ces
jeunes qui seraient normalement en
voyage à noël pour moi c'est la première
fois que je cherchais à palente ul parce
que chez nous à têtu il n'y a pas
vraiment de sympa comme sa fille chaud
au train où vont les choses les kiosques
d'arbres de noël se videront assez vite
qu'est ce que vous dites aux gens de
préférer celle d'avant il a choisi mais
c'est d'axéria vie de rentrer à date
qu'il est rentable seulement si on se
fie à l'année passée nous montrait comme
trop à quatre ça s'appelle il y à aussi
l'option d'aller le coupé soi même comme
viennent de faire leur ans et antoine
dans cette plantation de
sainte-anne-de-sorel tu viens un
contexte de pandémie et de prendre leur
pied des justement à faire une merde ça
fait toujours du bien au coeur
le propriétaire des lieux georges dutil
dit avoir deux semaines d'avancé sur ses
ventes répondent chaque année entre 1500
et 2000 arbres sont coupés sur sa
plantation comme plusieurs producteurs
il vend ses sapins environ cinq dollars
de plus que l'an dernier
bon là près autant vos phares métaux il
est un des deux cent soixante deux
producteurs de sapins au québec la
moitié se trouve en estrie
l'industrie est florissante la province
produit 71% des sapins de noël au pays
la hausse de la demande locale n'est pas
l'unique raison qui explique emilie
turcotte côté elle travaille chez un des
gros producteurs de la province
chaque année l'entreprise exporte 400000
sapin et surtout aux états unis et à au
moins 80 pour ça même peut-être jusqu'à
90% des arbres sont produits au québec
sont exportés aux états unis tout de
suite après l'onu et al 2010 9 en
janvier
nos achats avaient déjà réservé des
arbres parce que ça avec elle à avoir un
peu une pénurie
son message est le même n'attendez pas
trop pour acheter votre sapin ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal